[Music]
foreign
of the animated Kong series and at the
same time with the information from all
the comics as well as the monster verse
movies we now have a very clear timeline
of Skull Island from its very ancient
history to the modern times as well as
Beyond so let's get to it
millions of years ago it is unknown as
to what time the island actually came to
be but theories have it as it was way
back in the distant past that there was
a connection of Hollow Earth and Skull
Island via the entry points
millions of years ago through these
entry points there was a migration of
life forms from Beneath the Planet to
Skull Island hence it having a unique
blend of Flora and Fauna aren't seen
anywhere else in the world
unspecified so ewe myths happened that
there was an ancient Titan war on the
hollow Earth between the Gojira species
and the gongs and it is believed to be
instigated by Scar the red Kong and
Godzilla defeated him and imprisoned him
around 5000 to 1000 BC after the
devastated War the ewi tribes and the
remaining comes migrate to Skull Island
via the hollow Earth entry point making
it their new home
around 5000 BC to 1800 A.D over hundreds
and thousands of years the Evie and
Kongs create a magnificent civilization
on Skull Island as evident by the huge
structures and statues seen in the
island
the 1600s till the 1800s in the series
we see a scene of one of the characters
stumbling upon an imperial age sword in
a cave therefore this shows that
European explorers in the Pacific Ocean
got stranded and killed in the island
the late 1800s the cranium reptons or
the skull crawlers begin to emerge into
the island via the entry points and in
their massive numbers they waged a war
and preyed on both humans and cons on
the island
in the late 1800s during the last great
invasion of the skull crawlers the
civilization was wiped out and we see
the death of gong's parents and the
origins of our Kong in a flashback of
one of the characters in the comics the
birth of gong
1933 there was an alleged disappearance
of a filming crew on the island who set
out to investigate the rumors of an
island with exotic flora and fauna 1944
during World War II Two fighter planes
of the United States and Japan battle in
mid-air and were lost in the Pacific
this was hang Marlo and gunpei ikari
crash landing on Skull Island in the
beginning of the 2017 movie Kong Skull
Island
1973 led by Bill Randa this was the
first Monarch expedition to Skull Island
to investigate the hollow Earth theory
and document alleged rumors about the
island it was during this time that the
battle between Kong and ramara the skull
devil occurred and come defeated him
the late 1970s it is unknown as to when
this actually happened but Spanish
people got stranded on the island the
same ones seen in the series on that
Coastal Village
the early 1980s after his battles with
the giant chameleon Kong bathed in the
ocean and his blood awakens the Kraken
that had been dormant for over a long
time the awakened Kraken destroys the
Coastal Village giligong's friends and
hence starting the Rivalry between the
two Titans
the early 1980s a ship with Annie and
her father gets stranded on the nearby
Island which is a part of the skull
Island archipelago it was here that
Annie from the series befriends doll
which is a large canine-like creature
the early 1990s the Kraken devastates
ships nearby the island and this led to
the events of Skull Island series and a
final battle between the two Titans
which ended in calm killing the Kraken
in a bloody battle
August 1995 a secret expedition was led
by Monarch to Skull Island to proper
document the island but this led to the
death of the entire crew with only one
Survivor taking shelter with the iwi
tribes
2019 in kotm Guitar calls for Titans to
join the hunt and Destroy Humanity gong
resisted the call with the skullcrawlers
responded and began emerging from their
dormant States let's just say it was a
killing Festival of skullcrawlers by our
Big Ape
2019 to 2021 Monarch and Apex
cybernetics expand bases in Skull Island
after events of kotm this is evident by
their established presence as of the
timeline of Kingdom Kong as well as Apex
having skull crawler eggs as well as a
large specimen by the time of GVK
2021 camazod emerges and Kong battled it
out in the events of Kingdom Kong
causing havoc and chaos to the island
and alongside the bad Titan there were
many of his healthsware minions that
battle against the fighter aircrafts of
the U.S Navy the storm created by
camazods causes Havoc to skull Island's
ecosystem and the EV trap goes extinct
the storm stayed and hence the island
becomes unlivable as of the present time
2021 till 2025 a massive biodome is
built to house Kong and a surviving
species of the island this was done in
part by Monarch to study and preserve a
benevolent Titan in case there is need
for a deterrent against Godzilla
gong begins to destroy the Dome and due
to this he is transported away from
Skull Island in the events of GVK
leading to the ultimate battle with
Godzilla and Mecca G as well as Kong
relocating to the hollow Earth as of the
present the Storm still perpetuates in
Skull Island the biodome is probably
defunct and the remaining life forms are
either relocated or killed by the
extreme environmental conditions
so that is the timeline of Skull Island
in the monster verse anyway I hope you
have enjoyed watching this video do hit
the like button for support and
subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates and new
videos here on this channel take care
fam